see that that's the pixie dust that
Steve Jobs sprinkles over the audience
before every keynote to make sure that
we're all totally mesmerised by
everything he says and the truth is he's
one of the best keynote presenters in
the business today he showed us a whole
bunch of cool stuff including updates to
the iphone so new applications that look
pretty cool updates to iTunes we can now
download and view HD movies and we can
rent movies which is something that a
lot of people have been expecting any
updated Apple TV so that you can do all
the stuff that you can do in itunes you
don't need a computer you can download
movies directly to your Apple TV with
this nifty on screen interface it's all
pretty cool but not mind-blowing even
though people cheered loudly at every
single thing he announced the one
product that really did impress me is
the new macbook air which is a new super
thin and superlight notebook the way
it's just three pounds and it's about
three quarters of an inch thick at its
thickest part sort of wedge shape so it
looks very cool and yet it doesn't seem
to be much of a compromise it's got a
13.3 inch screen which is pretty big and
what jobs was calling a full-size
keyboard got an intel core 2 duo
processor and 2 gigs of ram it really
shows to me that jobs is not just a
showman but he's a really good CEO and
the Apple can really execute on
innovation I think this is going to be
really good for Apple in the market
because a notebook like this it's just
going to wow people I'm sure it's going
to sell a ton of units it's priced
pretty reasonably at about eighteen
hundred dollars so i expect this
notebook when it becomes available in
about two weeks to do really well one
sour note about this conference is that
it looks like registration is maybe a
little bit screwed up and the conference
maybe a little less well organized than
Macworld's usually are i I saw you on
the screen at the keynote
but you what I didn't see you in the
keynote yourself what's up they didn't
give me a media pass actually you a
media file so I don't know what's up
with that and then when we were setting
up outside this crazy Australian guy ran
by and practically assaulted our
producer demanding some kind of change
to the registration process another
person complained that lines out richest
outside the registration area were
incredibly long and he seemed pretty
upset too so hopefully next year
macworld will be a little better
organized and if you're coming this year
I hope you can get in